I hate seafood and I particularly hate
prawn probably a weird looking thing it
doesn't really taste of anything
the texture is meaty but it's the sort
of unpleasant if I presented you just
plain prawns now it would be traumatic
it's your lucky day because I have some
right here
it's just you see this what's this
little detail just really disgusting so
do you think I will be able to change
your mind about prawns today no that is
my mission
well good luck you go for it Chloe go
get in there so to change Jack's mind
I'm gonna make a smoky corn and chorizo
dish I'm just gonna cut up the prawns
Jack doesn't like the texture and little
curly tails freaked him out this is
gonna take that away for him got about 4
tablespoons of olive oil trying to warm
up so I'm gonna go in there with the
onions
and then I've got four really fat juicy
garlic cloves just finely chopped
Schmitt paprika I just want a little bit
of spice and you can do a lot pinch of
cayenne pepper and then trick so so I've
just got the pan on a low heat because I
just want to slowly cook this down I
want them to get nice and sweet and
juicy and all the flavors just slowly
come together I'm just gonna let this
sizzle for about 5 to 10 minutes
meanwhile I'm going to do the wine so
I'm gonna pair the dish with a beautiful
Chardonnay wine this wine is a really
really buttery and it's perfect with
fish so let's just taste up
that's so good he's gonna love it prawns
are going in next then we're gonna do a
big squeeze a lemon past me when I
season it with a bit salt pepper and
prawns it they cook so so quickly I
think people get scared cooking seafood
but the thing is it's so quick and easy
as soon as they turn pink they're done
start to finish with prep I reckon you
could get this done in my 15 minutes
let's serve up and this is finished so
let's go and see what he thinks
so here we are Jack okay we have
spanish-style king horns and turrets oh
wow with Chardonnay wine it's just going
to make the whole prawn experience
hopefully perfect Oh finally can I snow
yes smell it see what you think
not great not great I'll be honest
smells a little bit fishy okay let's
give it a go all right
and he's not screwed as that's good it's
really nice I'm astonished yeah but let
me see yeah battery wine down there oh
that's really cleanse the palate as well
it's really nice I'm really I'm
genuinely impressed by it doesn't look
like a little animal so much anymore the
chorizo and cayenne peppers were
balanced prawns out a little bit the
best bear is getting the bread and
mopping up all the oils in the garlic
you're right it's gonna and he's going
for the wine again would you say we've
changed your mind today then if I had
this yes but in any other context I'm
still wary but with this with the treat
so I think you've have changed my mind
amazing sees about the whole experience
perfect mission accomplished
[Music]
[Music]